analyst for NBC sports boston senior
writer for Sports Illustrated and at the
garden last night Chris thanks for
joining us describe the mood at the end
of the game in Boston after the loss to
the Bucks well I think it was a lot of
shock disbelief I mean that extends from
the stands into the locker room I mean
this was a game that Milwaukee looked
like they were ready to hand over to
Boston early I mean they struggled with
the three in the first quarter they
hadn't been doing that the last couple
of games with about nine minutes left
they only had 27 points I mean Boston
was in a great position to win and then
the third quarter comes around be honest
in some foul trouble and once again the
Bucks bench just ran over the Celtics
and the energy just vanished from that
lineup and yeah look this as I wrote
last night I mean this was the return of
the regular season felt like the same
kind of in different defensive
offensively selfish bunch that that that
plagued them during the regular season
and you know we can go down and talk
about a few different things Dan but
this is yeah LAN dis is on Kyrie Irving
it just is I mean he spent all season
you know basically you know downplaying
everything that was going on telling the
media telling everybody don't worry when
the playoffs come around we're gonna be
okay because I'm here well the last
three games Kyrie has been really bad
and and this is yeah this is as much on
him as does anybody else is that the
last time the Celtics fans see Kyrie
Irving I don't know it's too early to
say that because you know a lot can
happen in just the next couple of weeks
not just in the postseason but you have
to see where the ping-pong balls fall on
May 14th
you know if the Knicks wind up being the
number one pick that could affect Kyrie
Irving's decision if Boston you know
keeps the three first-round picks and
has that kind of nebulous Memphis pick
for the future
that's an interesting pick to some teams
that could factor in to Kyrie decision
especially when it comes to potentially
playing with Anthony Davis so I don't
think that you know we're you know I saw
that that the camera angle of Kyrie
walking alone Dan you know down the
hallway I don't think it
necessarily the last time we've seen in
play in Boston but you know if it is it
really is going out with a whimper yeah
there's a lot of fascination with what's
going on in the East with some of these
series because I you know I get the
feeling Kauai is not there for the long
haul in Toronto no matter what happens
you know Philadelphia with Brett Browne
if they don't move forward he could be
have his job in jeopardy you have what's
going on with the Celtics I mean the
Bucs we're the best team regular regular
season wise with best record and I think
this is maybe the series where people
are realizing they are a great team I
don't know if they're you know talent
wise but they're a great team and you
know Boston should be better than
Milwaukee in my opinion but that's a
credit to you know what Milwaukee has
done and what the Greek freak has done
and as we move forward but there are a
lot of storylines in the east and not
all of them are good no and with
Milwaukee there was a question from from
a lot of people that I talked to you
throughout the season about whether or
not they were a regular season team and
and if they could compete in the
playoffs and a lot of that came down to
inexperience the fact that Chris
Middleton was the second best player the
fact that they played Brook Lopez like
30 35 minutes in a game and Lopez had a
terrific regular-season but I was among
the people that had concerns that you
know kind of a lumbering 7-footer how is
he going to be a factor and in Game one
of the series it looked like I might be
right because Al Horford feasted on
Lopez and he couldn't make 3-point shots
but I'm watching the end of game four
last night man and there's Lopez making
defensive plays near the rim on Kyrie
Irving knocking down mid-range jumpers
knocking down you know laughs says he is
he comes off those pick and rolls he
played really well in that game he's
been a big factor in what that team has
done but they are they're complete I
mean they're they're inexperienced but
they're a complete team that is built
properly around a superstar like Yanis
who can just do do anything I mean Dan
he's shooting like 37 1/2 percent from 3
in the series if he does that for the
next few years in the regular season
forget the rest of the MVP like just
engrave it now and call it the Yanis
award because that's who's going to win
it for the
for five years if you had to bet on one
the Celtics win their series of the
Rockets win their series all rockets I
think the Rockets are on Golden State
level I was you know look there was a
lot of weirdness in those first couple
of games in Oakland with the referee
stuff and James Harden getting poked in
the eye but you know the when you what
they've done back in Houston there's a
lot more of what I thought was what they
were capable of but they're still you
know and I'm in a good spot funny
stretch they got to win one game in
Oakland that stuff but the way that
James Harden is playing and he saw
Austin Rivers make shots last night I
mean this team you talk about complete
teams like there they're as good as they
were last year with this group right now
and they're they're more confident
hungry than ever been before
yeah I made the analogy that Milwaukee I
think is a better team than Boston but
Boston's more talented I think Houston
is a better team than Golden State
Golden State has more talent do you buy
into that yeah especially with Golden
State being as thin as they are when the
Rockets aren't deep team either but you
know the guys they roll out there they
they all seem to trust each other a lot
and yeah I don't know what's going on
with Steph Curry's three-point shooting
if it's the finger that's bothering him
but but something has gone haywire there
with him in this series and a lot of
times it's you know they they try to run
a play it doesn't really work and it's
good the bulk Durant that asked him to
make something happen
offensively and klay Thompson but
discombobulated in this series too I
mean James Harden has his number in this
series so yeah I buy into that I buy
more on the other side with with
Milwaukee being a team and flossed have
natality boss we've got as much count as
anybody at least from Eastern Conference
maybe not the NBA it's it's you know
once again we're looking at Pima can't
put it together bodes yesterday on his
podcast I believe said that Monty
Williams
I believe turned down the Lakers to take
the Phoenix Suns job do you think that
Monty Williams did Monty Williams make
the right decision
I think he did and I've been saying for
a couple of weeks now the sun's job was
better than the Lakers job and and that
sounds crazy because the sun's job has
been a coaching graveyard for the better
part of the last five years Roberts
Arbor is like the James Dolan of the
West but but it it's a job with a lot of
upside and as wild as it sounds this may
be more stability with that job I mean
money William did the right thing
getting a five-year deal I mean I don't
think he would have taken that job
without a five-year deal because you
need that security when is all that
stuff going on behind the scenes but
they have James Jones now in places GM
and he's a really really smart guy and
they have Jeff Bower there to kind of be
his guide in terms of learning how to
run a front office on a day to day basis
and that was a smart move meanwhile the
Lakers I don't know who's making
decisions there may Rob blank is in
charge but Linda rhombuses and meetings
Kurt Rambis is involved with this stuff
you've got a young team on the rides and
LeBron James needs to win right now I
mean I understand like if the suns wind
up with like the fourth pick it becomes
less appealing with that slot but if
they wind up with one or two and choose
this is good for them because I think
John Moran would be perfect playing
alongside Devin Booker if they wind up
one of those top two picks they're in
tarrant business and I think Monty
Williams saw that you know we we've
talked about Anthony Davis in this
destination in the offseason
and feels like foregone conclusion he's
leaving New Orleans but you know Boston
can make a better offer than the Lakers
are the Lakers and what else can they do
to ramp this up and then I wouldn't rule
out the Clippers here Chris because I I
mean if you're the Clippers why wouldn't
you go after Anthony Davis if you think
you have a chance at Kawhi Leonard you
know klay Thompson doesn't work out a
Golden State it just feels like the
Clippers are sort of they're lurking
waiting to make a really really big move
oh they're definitely lurking
I don't know that Davis is a priority
for them right now you know what they
see is a a slot that a Kawhi Leonard or
a Kevin Durant or maybe both you know
they'll probably pursue both will will
fit into a wing position scoring slot
that they badly need and that they think
that this team they have
you put one or two of those players
around them and you might be the best
team in the Western Conference next year
and you know it's different with trade
because that's going to be tricky
especially if Austin really gets into
the mix because we say this a lot but
you can't outbid Boston if they really
want somebody they're gonna go and get
him because of all the draft takes and
young players that they have I don't
think the Clippers want to get into that
not when they have a really strong
chance of landing at Kauai or Kevin
Durant and look they're gonna be maybe
the most impressive team in free agency
when they get in the room with guys
because you're gonna have Lawrence Frank
who's uber prepared Doc Rivers who
everybody respects and and their owner
is not a net negative as so many other
owners are I mean Ballmer gets in the
room and start cleaning and dancing and
telling um how much money he's gonna
spend guys like that like he's he's kind
of a perfect owner for that situation
throwing Southern Californians
you know they're just gonna when they
get into these meetings and I've heard
this from a lot of different executives
as I kind of ramped up a free agency it
they're gonna be a force when I get into
these meetings they're to the point
where if it's you know borderline
they're probably may get their guy well
so I bring out the logo to I have him
you know slip into the meeting and say
oh by the way here's the logo jerry west
well it's him and look I know Lawrence
is gonna be incredibly prepared for this
and you bring Jerry cuz that makes me
huh how do you beat that I mean yeah
like from last year you had a couple
years ago yeah the Hamptons five and yet
you know the all the waters going out
there and that's that certainly
resonates with a player we have that
much star power telling you that that
you want them to play there but if
you're looking for structure and if
you're looking for some kind of
stability that the worth of us are the
Clippers offering space there they're
built to win right now in both of the
roster and the front office good to
visit with you Chris safe travels during
the postseason we'll check in with you
soon
you got again that's Chris Mannix he's
analyst for NBC Sports Boston and a
senior basketball and boxing writer for
Sports Illustrated for more Dan Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
Direct TV stream for free on VR live or
download the Dan Patrick show at